thank you for coming to this talk we're
already 5 minutes late I think I'll try
to keep it within time so this talk is
on building a recommendation engine
using Python which is a type of
predictive analytics and before I dive
more into the topic I will tell you a
little bit about me so I am data Sai my
name is Anasuya I am data scientist at
Texas Advanced Computing Center TAC it
is an independent research center at UT
Austin it is one of the largest
supercomputer center with Rich's HIPAA
compliant we have about 250 people
working in this lab in the super
computer lab and we collaborate with
mostly the other National Labs and
federal government agencies so we work
on many classified projects and very
innovative and novel novel projects so
one example of our work would be how to
better predictive analytics for the
weather system so that it it balances
the equals our ecosystem things like
that and recommendation on earthquakes
these are a few example of the kind of
work that we do we work a lot with
patient data also like predicting
diseases predicting drugs for specific
diseases so we work a lot with life
sciences like genome sequencing those
kind of data also and being a
supercomputer Center we work on large
scale computing problems so we have
several supercomputers which work on
very powerful GPUs as well as then the
data analytics we have a supercomputer
called Wrangler which came out recently
and it works specifically on data
analytics portion I will show you a
little bit of the interface that I have
here so this is the interface in
Wrangler where you can go and you you do
not have to setup any cluster you can
just set say in the request new Hadoop
reserved
here you can just say how many nodes you
want and for how many days it will just
spin up a cluster for you so that the
data scientists just needs to take care
of the experiments that they do n just
do not worry about setting up a cluster
and things like that so once you set up
this oh okay you are assigned Hadoop
clusters like this and you can just go
into your cluster and start working so
this is a very typical example of how we
work now on the motivation of my talk
today why do we need recommendation
engines or recommendation systems at all
I mean there are many packages many
libraries already existing so why do we
need another new one most of the cases
we have seen that most of the packages
that are readily available whether it's
open source or pure buy it
those packages actually take into
consideration mostly numerical data they
do not take into consideration image
processing text analytics recommendation
on these kind of data are very
unstructured data so the main motivation
behind behind this recommendation engine
was to build an in-house one which we
can store in the Wrangler supercomputer
where people could come and just grab
that code and run it with their own
dataset so it's as Wrangler iran's on
Hadoop and spark infused platform so
spark PI spark can actually if your code
is in Python by spark can actually take
the utilize the Hadoop HDFS system
underlined and they can you can process
very big data sets in Wrangler and if we
put this our our hybrid a recommendation
model which we I'm going to talk about
there you can just come in and it can do
recommendation on your own data set so a
brief outline of my talk today it's I've
said that recommendation systems are the
type of predictive analytics we'll just
compare and see how it is I will give
you a brief introduction of recommender
systems types of recommender systems
existing recommender systems for PubMed
docume
as I work mostly with medical data I've
chosen PubMed document and will to a
hybrid model of recommender systems on
PubMed documents going forward this
could be used on any kind of documents
any text format if you want to work it
on your own kind of data like
specifically image it does it we would
have you can contact me and we would
have we can collaborate and we are
always looking for collaborations intact
we can collaborate and work together on
it
and I'll give you also a brief workflow
and a live demo of small case of a small
case of the system like I cannot show
you on the supercomputer it will just
take forever I've just shown you a local
live demo of how we go about doing this
so before comparing for comparing the
predictive analytics and recommender
systems I go to the data analytics go
back a step so I go back to data
analytics and we see here that mainly
three types of data analytics are
existing here descriptive predictive and
prescriptive so descriptive is the very
like the simple type of data analytics
that you can do it just gives you an
aggregate view of your data and just
takes the data and breaks it up into
small useful chunks so that you can have
a very top level view the while symmetry
of the statistics that we use like
Psalms averages percentage changes this
kind of things are falls under
descriptive analytics next which is
enraged nowadays predictive analytics it
tries to it takes your data and tries to
predict a trend in your data
it is a probabilistic prediction it does
not give you the future it just gives
predicts what will happen with your data
in future so one kind of predictive
analytics example very common one is
sentiment analysis or one such example
would be if if you're trying to find out
whether your email is spam or not you
can apply sentimental it's and it will
predict based on the sentiment of the
the sentiment of the
that whether it's a bomb or not the next
type of relative in assets which we'll
talk about today is is prescriptive
prescriptive analytics it is a subset of
predictive analytics that means that
recommendation system which is a type of
predictive analytics is a subset of
predictive analytics and it helps
prescribe or recommend an action to end
users
it helps recommend data to end users
taking into consideration what kind of
data you have
it helps drive decision based involve
decision based ideas on your data now
what are recommender systems recommender
systems is to say it in a single line it
helps match users with items but it can
be done in many ways you can take I mean
the very basic form is you're trying you
take very form basic form of
recommendation still in search so when a
user comes in and searches it's it's
it's a kind of recommendation you can
say but it's very static I mean it is
not it is not like whether you it will
give you futuristic predictions it will
just give you whatever you have searched
for then so but the recommender systems
going we'll see going forward there are
many different types and different types
is used with different motivation and
for different users based on the kind of
data you have available based on the
kind of question you want to ask out
this out of the system we will try and
develop some with PubMed documents so
why do we need recommendation it's as
data is becoming more and more big it's
becoming overwhelming for anybody to
have a context in whatever they are
searching for so if you are if you're
looking for a for some for for a topic
related thing it's very difficult it's
becoming more and more hard for the
search engines to predict something
based on your topic based on your
context so that's why recommendation
systems are becoming more and more
essential nowadays
the emerge of more and more big data so
the type of recommender systems there
are mainly or broadly three types of
recommendation systems but we see or one
is like the knowledge-based where where
you actually try to engineer the
knowledge which bootstrap the knowledge
whatever you have available and try to
recommend your static recommendation but
as I explained it's the search but it
comes with but it comes with some pros
and cons I mean the con is basically
static and the Pro is it does not have a
cold start problem so let me describe
the cold start problem and with respect
to recommendations and recommendation
systems here so when when a new user
comes in or a new item comes into your
Karpis I'm taking just a document
dataset for for the ease of
understanding when a new document comes
into your corpus it's very hard to have
any idea about that document and predict
based on that document so you have to
build up a user profile or an item
profile before you can start predicting
on the trend of that item how similar
they are to the existing items or how
what interests the user have for first
who is searching for items so in take a
very particular example of Netflix if
somebody is only searching for animation
related movies and suddenly the
starching start searching searching for
action village action genre movies it's
very difficult to predict how they would
rate action genre movie because they do
not have the user do not have a profile
based on action genre movies they the
user only have profile based on of
animated movies so that kind of probe
like a pre-processing our pre data is
required for the recommendation systems
to start not having that data is called
a cold start problem so as we can see
knowledge base because it's static it
does not require a cold stuff it does
not go under cold start problem you can
any new user can come in and search for
whatever item is present no previous
user profile history is required for
content-based recommendation
can't as I explained we can understand
that it has a good Nicole start problem
for new users but the process comparison
between the items which is present is
very easily possible based on the
content so if your data is elaborate
enough if it supports enough information
then compras in between items can be
easily done using content-based
recommendation content which the
recommendation can also be context
dependent so if you go in and search for
documents the document searching is
mostly content based but you try to
capture the context of your searches so
suppose your searching for one type of
DNA so it should be known whether it's
you're interested in a human DNA or a
mouse DNA so if you just search for DNA
random data will be coming up so so that
you need based on the user profile we
can understand what kind of DNA the user
is interested in whether he or she is
working with human DNA our mouths DNA so
that's the caching of the current
caching of the context of the content
that's what we call context of the
content it gives you more relevant
recommendations the most widely used
type of recommendation is the
collaborative filtering technique it
gives you a recommend it has call start
problem for new users and new items
however it gives you very innovative and
very accurate recommendations
we'll see how how it works so a commonly
used example of user based collaborative
filtering is we try we take this data a
small data and we try to predict new
books to customers see who is
highlighted there so we see that a
customer sees bought book two and three
and customer B is very similar in
content and context to customers C in
the sense that they have also have
bought a book two and three customer D
is also related close very closely
related but he or she has bought only
book two not three so we apply weights
based on the closeness
there are ways to measure this kind of
similarity we'll go into it but yes
based on the similarity we weight that
customer B is more closer in hiring
ranking in closeness to customer C than
customer B so book 5 which is searched
by customer V would be more highly
recommended than book 6 who which
customer D had actually searched for so
customer book so book 5 will be more
highly recommended to book C than book
Dan book 6 as you can see a and B are
have didn't have no overlapping results
so their rates will be really small it
would not take be taken into
consideration compared to B and D okay
next a new kind of recommendation
systems it is also widely used is called
hybrid recommendation system so you can
as I showed you three sorry three
different kinds of data here there's
three different types of recommendation
technique here you can combine any two
of the Stickney two or more of this
technique you can come by two three you
can combine them and it will give you a
hybrid recommender systems as you can
see here you can capture the user
information you can capture the content
which is the product features you can
also my knowledge based on search and
combine them together to give you a
recommendation so why do we need hybrid
models for recommending pubmed documents
what existing one would not do as I said
rate event users go into PubMed I do not
know if you are a very public PubMed is
medical data like articles corpus it's a
it's abstracts are readily usable for
our experiment we have used only it's
licensed on the MEDLINE so but for our
experience we have used only the full
documents which are open source
available we have not used the MEDLINE
license so as as its as there is no
option for the users like a Netflix
users can go in and rate movies and
recommendation is easy
easy based on building a user's profile
on those ratings but in case of PubMed
kind of a system it's very difficult
user goes in searches and it gives you
just the documents which which is being
searched for they do not get to rate the
documents so it becomes very difficult
to based on how new documents would be
recommended to them so there are steps
that we go for go ahead with for
combining these recommender system for
pubmed documents is research whatever
query or whatever document we need to we
are interested in we do an information
retrieval based for users based on
content and context and then we
recommend context related documents to
user based on context related on with
the search so there are some steps that
we go over for combining we use the
vector space model which is which is
actually a type of an information
retrieval system we combine step one and
two step one is content-based filtering
on PubMed documents so we search
documents with query term we tokenize
each document into a combination of
unique terms we compare the pubmed
document we convert the cup by
Department document to a sparse matrix
of documents and terms so the next step
is we wait the query term which is
coming so we take a document we actually
tokenize it and create unique term set
for each and every document and when the
query comes and we try to compare a
similarity documents matrix similarity
how similar each and every query is - -
to the documents they are searching for
based on that we assign rights and
that's how you can as you can say okay
this is this ranking is very similar to
a Netflix or user rating so we are
generating the ratings or the ranking of
the documents from its content for that
we use the vector space model as I said
I'll I'll actually show you what better
vector space model is Alex
after this so this backward that was
step two and three four to one and two /
three we filtered the whatever
now that our documents are rated and
ranked we filter that using
collaborative filtering technique that
is recommendation for this purpose we
use an open-source Python library called
Python rexes it was developed by Oskar
Selma director of research at Pandora
and it works very accurately so once you
have your numerical data and your
document ranks although all these things
involve information retrieved rated and
ranked you can go then go ahead and use
a standard recommendation library we
used pandas for pre-processing of the
data we use ski kit to evaluate our
model here we try to do two types of
recommendations item best recommendation
and user based recommendation however I
will tell you depending on your data
your pre-processing technique and steps
would be different I mean I have only
worked with documents if you are you're
working with image data obviously your
pre-processing steps to prepare data and
wait and rank your data would be
different next we see how IR is done
through information retrieval is done
through vector space model so what do we
have we have a set of pubmed documents
we have n features n features is the
number of terms into which you divide
unique terms that you tokenize your
document into describing the documents
in the set so these each each and every
document will be divided from 0 to n
terms and whenever a term is not
occurring in the matrix it will be 0 or
not a number so but but what happens is
yeah but what happens is it actually
does not work as expected we have
converted this into a sparse matrix so
working on sparse matrix is different
than usually available matrix we'll see
how we work on this farce matrix going
forward so
so query is also when the term comes
after the IR when the query comes in it
is represented as a point in the vector
space so we apply tf-idf term frequency
in the document frequency to tokenize
documents to weigh the documents and
convert the documents to vector we
compute cosine similarity between the
tokenize documents and the query term
will select the top three documents
based on the similarity measure and
recommend those three documents as the
first step of of our ir yeah sure it is
very similar it is very similar but the
vector space actually takes the content
as well as the context so it tries to
compute a distance similarity based on
the context of your content yes it's one
step further so these are available
recommendation libraries so each each
one of them works better but depending
on what kind of question or what kind of
data you have from my purpose I chose
Python rexis so why did I choose Python
vexes so it is obviously as I was
writing code in Python it is a Python
library for building recommendation
engines it works very well with ski kit
modules for collaborative filtering
content and hybrid filtering so it it
actually works very well with ski kit
and the underlying module is K SVD which
is very generalization of the k-means so
you have and and it actually handles
sparse matrix state as I said we have
already were converted and it actually
converts into sparse matrix with only
the numbers our origin note coming in n
in n by n features in an N by n matrix
you get only numbers where terms are
occurring and most of the other spaces
are empty so that's how the sparse
matrix is created and it is open source
obviously you can go and
look at the code here as I have seen
given you the code for Python Rexes it
is very easily installable it's
installed through easy install pip
things like that so it's very it it
actually we've seamlessly integrates
with your model so now we will move on
to the code execution of the demo we
shall try to show that our hybrid model
which is a combination of the vector
space model and Python recommendation
Python rexes that works better than
using Python rex's library alone so
that's what the motivation is showing
that our model works better so first we
explain the collaborative filtering
technique using Python resource library
on a simple movie data set because I
have ratings already available and movie
data set
next we explain our hybrid model for
PubMed recommendation so we come we run
comparative evaluations on the model
like the ritual we will run root mean
square error and mean absolute error so
root mean square error give these two
actually tries to let the error be more
correct your model so root mean square
gives you accuracy of your model mean
absolute error gives you accuracy of
your prediction
so lower these numbers better is both
the numbers because those are errors so
but so better your model works so try to
see so the data
I used use for demo is a movie data
format a set is like this we have a user
ID we have a movie ID and the ratings so
this was downloaded from the internet
it's very easily available data set if
you search for movie data set just for
your testing purposes you'll get this
kind of perform at this document which
is for the PubMed dataset format a lot
of pre-processing is required but it
then you come to when it will pre
process your data like the tokenize and
those kinds of things I mean that is
done through the vector space model I've
integrated into our vector space model
so when you do that you get your data in
this format so you have a user name a
unique user ID the query term which you
are searching for the document
the and the document rank this document
rack is the tf-idf score which is being
scored by comparing how similar the term
is to the content of the of your
document then you have the document name
and each dog talk each dr. Kane and
combined dr. case I'll explain this when
you talk it when you search for
something like DNA top three matching
the documents would be picked up so each
document has got unique terms and we
tokenize that document now we try to
combine those terms and take only the
union of those document terms like three
document terms and do a union on them so
that we get the unique combination of
the terms for that search so next time
when we do a recommendation we only take
the combined document tokens so that we
have a larger space for recommending lot
more likely items so that is used for
item two items Corinne before I go to
conclusion I can just go here and run
the demo so first we load the data set
here as you can see yes first we load
the data set here as you can see so we
import all the packages the recommend
directs this algorithm which is the
Python recommendation aisle algorithm it
imports as SVD it tries to import a data
which will actually take your data into
some specific format and then we try to
evaluate now are we load our data set
I'm not running this because it will
take a little bit of time so that's why
I'm not running this I've already done
this but okay I can start running it
actually
okay it ran and now I try to load the
data which is being loaded and this is
the movie data set data that I showed
you it has got a movie ID a user ID and
the rating given by the user for that
movie so now that this is run we try to
do for our testing purpose we try to
split the data set and we take 80% as as
the training data set and 20 personnel
is testing data set the next step is
computing off SVD so here I take K as
100 so I could have taken less also
because the movie data set which I'm
considering is not that big it's 1
million so K is actually so now in this
model we have like consider K means it's
very similar to that so consider it will
be hundred centroids would be considered
and now we try to computer this document
similarity based on the distance from
those centroids and that's how SVD is
computed here on your training dataset
once that is computed you actually try
to test how accurate your model is and
for that we run it and root mean square
error and mean absolute error to be
given so you're calling those functions
you're trying to predict generator
predicted rating and now you're testing
whether your predicted rating is how
similar they are to your reading so as
we can see accuracy of this model is not
very good because it's coming to point
nine zero seven three things like that
and mean absolute error is coming to
zero seven one zero point seven one so
which is also very higher it should be
less than 0.5 to be very accurate so I'm
in realism 0.5 but yes it should be less
than 0.5 the next step that we do
computers I tend to item similarity so
we take Toy Story and we take bug's life
because we are only having IDs I've
given out the names from the movie Etta
so we are trying to compute an SBD
similarity we see that they are similar
but it is not the similarity should be
high errors should be low but the
similarity should be very high so we see
that it's not very similar it cannot in
here it's not capturing the content of
the movie in any sense are the context
of the movie in any sense it's only
doing recommendation on the user given
ratings so that's why the similarity it
cannot capture the similarity very well
so so the SVD similarity when we compute
here for one item like how how to get
movies in my Karpis which is same or
similar to Toy Story and I get something
like this the story story urge is 1 and
point 8 1 which is quite high is is my
most close closer movie to Toy Story and
I see that is that is Toy Story 2 so I
start Story 2 so that that is doing a
good job actually in this in this case
so next we try to see which users should
see Toy Story movie we try to then
recommend now here we computed the
similarity between the movie now here we
try here trying to recommend users for
this movie to move this movie to users
so which which user would be most
interested in getting in getting this in
guessing this document and we see that
user 869 it would be most interested to
to actually see this movie based on the
movie rating so now we move on to that
was based on only collaborative
filtering only item in user based on
ratings so now we move on to a PubMed
example and try to show how our how our
model is working so here first we pre
process and load the data set I've just
given all the steps first we previously
load the data sets in a database we do
information retrieval and weighing of
documents using vector space model and
we save the output back to database and
then we run recommendation Rex's library
on that data set
were on that stored data that and
already ranked data so it works like
this it it asks you the search query and
it asks you the user who is searching
for that query and then we compute SVD
as I said using Python Rexes once it's
stored in database and then we try to
compute similarity between two documents
get the similar documents so when this
is search document the user is user ID
is 11 username is Rita document ID is
actually the PubMed ID and Reese and and
and we see the whole name of the of the
document is given out so we are trying
to compute which item in the pubmed is
most similar so it's rabid OPS's a DNA
which is a kind of a maze that means DNA
which we are working with so it's very
unique right it should not give you
documents which it should not recommend
your documents which is human DNA our
mouths DNA so we see that for for if you
search for seven eight six six zero two
five ID seven seven seven three zero one
seven is recommended let's see what this
documents are so this is seven eight six
six zero two five which I searched for
and it is molecular dissection of g1
from rabid OPS's it has got DNA related
data from rubber OPS's and this item is
recommended triple seven three zero one
seven is this also related to rabid
opposites as you can see so and it gives
you marieee closely related it tries to
see the cDNA and the RNA and that's how
that's what that's how we can say that
our model is working pretty close it's
not recommending human or Mouse related
documents and user base similarity we
try to find users who have previously
searched for this Rob topsis DNA kind of
a data and we try to find out who they
are so we see that user eight is very
similar to user 11 and going back here
in the database we see that user eight
has actually searched for DNA and based
on that a rabid OPS's because that is
only did and he could the database could
find related to DNA which was located
because this is a small sample so you
met other users have not not search for
rabbit upsets DNA but one user have
searched for DNA so that users profile
is actually suggested back and based on
that these three documents is actually
recommended so seven eight six six nine
five seven six and seven seven let's go
and see if that is what is recommended
and we sorry and we see that those are
the three documents from user eight
which are recommended so I can run the
code and show you actually so this is
the vector space model it this document
calculates the document ID item
prediction and this one calculates the
user document user prediction so if I
run this vector space model I have
actually called those recommendations
from my vector space model modularly so
it will be called so let us run this and
try and see so if I'm searching for mRNA
and I'm searching I'm searching for
another user say my name it will
generate data saying ok mRNA is being
searched by onion and I'm creating a
user profile for Anu and we are trying
to predict whatever document you will be
being searched for the top three
documents which are wrong similar to the
search documents are these three which
I'm highlighting can you see that I like
yeah okay so and as you can see the root
mean square error and the mean absolute
error are pretty small here it's not
point 9 1 or 0.75 as we were getting
using only the collaborative filtering
so we are getting we are getting pretty
much pretty very
very low error specifically it does very
well with user recommendation though the
above three which I showed you is item
two item recommendation but these this
is when it comes to user based
similarity like which users should be
recommended movie should be recommended
documents it does that accuracy is much
higher there so it's point three here at
point three 4.30 so as you can see it's
there it's recommending very correctly
in in this case okay so the conclusion
Python Rex's is very accurate as we saw
and the prediction of how related titer
is story two is to toy toy story said it
is very accurate recommendation library
yeah and that's why we use it so the
hybrid model increased the prediction
recommendation accuracy as I showed it
actually reduces both the errors and
gives you a very high accuracy we have
got a great community support for this
both we at them as well as for Python
mixes and any Python related library
package to that to say to talk about so
that's why we students chose part of
Python to work on this and the actually
the cons are paralyzation is not that
great so when we took when we took this
model to to work in PI in using PI spark
ml live in our supercomputer it does not
that curacy reduces actually it does not
do that that well I think it's mostly
because we have to install if you're
using a modular kind of a Python you
have to install it in different nodes
and that reduces the accuracy for Big
Data we need to use different functions
instead of SVD as we doesn't do very
good on like huge it depends if you have
like petabytes of documents it would not
be able to compute very easily because
then you have to choose a K and being
there being many documents many
like non related documents would also be
given similar distances and they would
all be clustered together so really do
not perform very well on big data there
is something called SVD lib which
actually works very well with big data
so acknowledgments are used for these
previous users works with FRA and from
that the motivation is derived and that
was my talk thank you do you have any
questions